my talk at the table is about the
exploding popularity of a reggaeton
music and at the center of all that is a
Colombian singer-songwriter whose music
you probably know
[Music]
her name is Carol G and she is a Latin
American Mega star whose music videos
have been viewed billions of times she
has performed at Coachella did so last
summer and she's now gearing up for the
release of her new album Lilia Luciano
recently met up with Carol G at a
Colombian restaurant here in New York
City to talk about how she Rose to Fame
by breaking all the reggaeton rules
she calls herself a bichota which
roughly translates to badass and over
these last three years Carol G's Fame
has exploded my vision and my mission
with all the things that I do is just to
touch the people's heart is like
amazinger and my idea is to like
inspired or or create a good moment or a
good remember or something for the
people that listen to my music she's
reaching fans all over the globe with 59
million Instagram followers and 38
million monthly Spotify listeners she's
collaborated with artists like Bad Bunny
and Nicki Minaj your career is larger
than life it's so massive when you were
a little kid in Medellin how big did you
dream when I was a child my father all
the time put me to sing in every like
party
in every like show opportunity
everywhere everything just started like
that then I just learned that I could
live into this as like the career of my
life born in Medellin Colombia as
Carolina Geraldo Navarro she adopted the
stage name Carol G after appearing on
the country's children's version of X
Factor as a young team
but she didn't get far and her rise was
neither quick nor easy you're dead was
disappointed when you wanted to stop
singing very
hungry upset he was very upset and why
was that what did he tell you my father
was convinced in a certain way like he
was sure that we were going to get it
and he kept all the time like telling me
like baby
if this is going to take us years and
it's gonna be hard and whatever is like
the the gift
and the success and the result is gonna
be like 10 times bigger so it's worth it
so let's keep doing it like so please
don't stop believe me we walked out and
there's already a crowd there for me and
now I'm I'm trying to keep like focused
meetings with record labels and business
Executives were discouraging they were
like hey you're a woman doing reggaeton
and that's not gonna happen but we want
your lyrics We want to be in a composer
from different artists and I was like no
I don't want this like I compose my own
songs and I want to keep doing this for
my music I don't want to do it like for
nobody else at that time I thought it
was like a bad decision that I took but
now I am very happy that I just followed
myself so the message keep being the
same it's like uh there is a lot of
people that have limits in their minds
eventually she broke through and in 2016
Carol G signed with Universal Music
Latino as a reggaeton singer two years
later she won the Latin Grammy Award for
Best New Artist you say you've learned
difficult lessons and you kind of want
to save people from them can you talk to
me a little bit about what have been
those difficult lessons if I'm a young
up and coming you know artist in the
music industry or especially in rayadong
or music Urbana yeah like first uh that
thing to try to fit it's don't waste
your time don't try to feel like just be
you and embrace that and make like take
advantage of your difference because
that's gonna like make you different
with somebody else so maybe that's like
something that I was trying to do like
really hard started like I don't know
like I'm I was trying to wear things out
like were in in fashion maybe I was
trying to speak in a way maybe I was
trying to have my hair and my makeup and
to do music in a in a certain way that
was good for people to listen to I
really wanted no I didn't want it uh to
be judged for nothing like I was trying
to be perfect in all the ways because I
was just wanted for the people to like
me no matter what make everybody happy
exactly born from Jamaican reggae and
dance hall Panamanian rap hip-hop and a
lot of Puerto Rican genius reggaeton has
often placed women at the center of the
song but historically more as the object
rather than the subject Carol G's lyrics
are still raw and steamy but instead
come from the perspective of the female
gays you got the billboard rule breaker
award and I can think of many moments
where I've listened to your music and
I'm like oh my god a woman singing about
how we women actually like and enjoy sex
we are human humans just have same like
experiences no matter if it's a boy if
it's a girl and I think that's why I
connected with my people is because they
they find their lives in a song honesty
breaks through in every track of her new
album you have had very public breakups
that everybody wants to talk about and
then you make a song or a series of
songs that it's like you're pouring your
heart at some point you need to talk
about it for sure people know that I
came from a really hard broke up and
that's like the result of my album a lot
of songs came from that but I need to be
honest that a lot of songs came from my
experience for an artist with an open
heart the highest highs can also lead to
even lower lows being so public she says
is challenging and often feels isolating
your tour was one of the top 10 world
tours
the most dream Latina on Spotify from
the outside I'm thinking you are in your
most glorious moment why was it
difficult what were you going through I
don't know it's kind of touching when
you speak I think I'm a little bit
sensitive today but um
it's not everything about numbers and
charts it was hard because everybody was
seeing that I was in the top of my
career but maybe in my inside I was
losing like the most valuable things in
my life I had a moment in my life that I
was very away from my family and my
friends and and to find that again and
to connect with that again was hard but
with her new album my nana cerrabonito
meaning tomorrow will be beautiful Carol
G is more focused on what lies ahead why
did you choose this name for the album I
always tried to keep like a positive
attitude for everything and I talk a lot
to myself like all the time and all
those moments I was like
letting myself feel sad letting myself
like feel as I cry and and a lot of
things and just keep in my mind like
maybe tomorrow is going to be different
and maybe tomorrow is going to be
beautiful I'm curious what does this
moment mean for you the release of this
new album it was hard to finish the
album for me with that I'm very
perfectionist because I really want the
people to
connect with everything with the sound
with the lyric with the visuals so at
heart and I think I'm ready I think
I want to see what people is going to
feel when they listen to the album
and Manana sigas because the album with
all of its female empowerment sexy
tracks and songs about self-love finally
drops tonight at midnight it includes
collaborations with Phineas Sean Paul
and a much anticipated Duo that's out
today with Shakira as well as Romeo
Santos from Aventura nice it was so nice
to meet her the way that you showed us
and it just shows you you never know
what's going on in people's lives
because you look at this young woman she
appears to be at the top of her game and
she is yes but there's other stuff going
on I like when you said the object
rather than the subject in many of the
music that's powerful and she changed
that well as a little girl growing up in
Puerto Rico hearing reggaeton you know
you all you obviously feel like you're
in the middle of the song and you're
dancing and it feels like you're the
object but she's singing from that
female gaze and it's so empowering I
told her I listened to your music when
I'm driving late at night to a story and
it's only the seat belt that keeps me
safe
thank you so much